i want to show you guys this story from
the daily news because it's kind of
silly but it's also kind of freaky
hardy's seizes on mike lindell's fbi
drama to sell pillowy biscuits
no joke
the fast food chain what is this hardy
har har thanks daily news fast food jane
hardy seized on being included in the
headlines about alleged confiscation of
my pillow's ceo mike lindell cell phone
with an ad promoting something the
bombastic businessman might enjoy
now that you know we exist you should
really try our pillowy biscuits
lindell a spirited conspiracy theorist
has worked tirelessly blah blah blah the
point here is
we're at the point where fast food
chains are making memes of the collapse
of of our country to sell
fast food
those biscuits are a little tasteless
in my opinion
but you know i make jokes references to
gulags just kind of being
sensationalistic and hyperbolic but
am i that far away i mean where do you
see the the road ending with this
because we see the groundwork being laid
down by hillary clinton by joe biden by
kamala harris by uh congressman
tim ryan today saying very hyperbolic
statements against you know the mega
republicans where does this end because
i think they just started and i think
they're just laying down the groundwork
for something very serious that could be
very dangerous for everyone the white
house spokesperson said that if you
disagree with them you're an extremist
okay yeah and they are trying to
criminalize all political disagreement
yeah look i'm a
i'm a happy warrior and so i don't want
us to all
go out and jump out of the building here
um
you know i just think that this is
but it is very very serious without
question you know we are a time when
when where we've never been in this
country
and i think if people don't take it
seriously which i think they are across
the country but i can guarantee you the
beltway
doesn't understand what's going on they
don't understand the anger when you get
out to the this i mean look you're not
very far outside of oh it's it's my
country
and you can tell i mean you know people
i was i was at an event earlier tonight
i mean people are scared people are
pissed
and and and that's what's happening so
you have essentially a split in this
country it's not so much red state's
blue states
it's city-states
versus the rest of america so it just
depends like here in maryland you know
it's a blue state largely because
baltimore right right and and the outs
the suburbs of washington dc everywhere
else red and getting redder and the same
the same thing is is true in in my part
of california uh where i'm from you know
i'm halfway between la and san francisco
so look
i want to be positive i want to believe
in the constitution i want to but you
know clearly
you know look i left congress
you know not because i i you know i
needed a new job and trump didn't need a
new company but it's pretty bad when i
got to leave congress solely because i
believe that the communications
platforms are so broken that we have no
way to get our message out we can't even
communicate with one another and we're
in the middle of a propaganda war that's
destroying this country where it's
pushing
city states getting moving hard left and
everybody else moving hard right and
that heart in the in the in the when i
say hard right meaning you know
conservative where they can't even
communicate with one another and we're
constantly dealing with with fake news
and censorship i don't even think it's
moving hard right i mean my politics are
basically in the same spot they've
always been except on second amendment
i think for a lot of people especially
people in my situation it's that the
left has just continually gone further
and further left elon musk posted that
meme you saw it i'd imagine where do you
see this one it's like left and right
and then years later left to move but
he's staying in the same spot and it's
just moving further and further left the
left likes to use that and say see this
proves it
if you still believe the same things you
did 10 years ago you are conservative
you're traditionalists you're not
progressive that's their argument so
they're actually saying yeah we agree
with that you are now on the right it
has changed but i got to tell you man
what's really scary is
i know people
that uh i used to consider friends
and they've gone insane
they've actually gone insane the things
they believe they believe every hoax
from the media they believe justice
millet oops that was a hoax they believe
the russiagate stuff they believe hands
up don't shoot they believe the ahmed
arbory story they believe the trayvon
martin stuff they believed all of that
and even after all of it the covington
catholic kids even after all that is
debunked in the media they still
believe it
we know those stories are fake they
still believe the lies every day right
and they're full of anger is the crazy
thing the messages i see on on on
facebook you know there's a few people
i've known my whole life who still like
they're they're very liberal they're
very anti-trump but they still talk to
me and they say listen to me and they go
oh i don't know that good friends but i
know some people that
they've gone nuts and i'm wondering if
you guys have experienced the same thing
like people who have become totally just
i don't even want to say trump
derangement it's like
it's it's
right-wing derangement but it's not even
that it's if you're outside of the cult
they just believe whatever they're told
by the media yeah well maybe a good uh
example for
you is this
so when i when i went when i was elected
to congress 2002
bernie sanders was in the house of
representatives a lot of people
forgot that that he was actually a
member of the house for a very long time
and i remember
a lot of the first votes i i'd look up
on the screen you know there's always a
lot of votes and you know a lot of them
are
are a lot of bills that they get to get
through they don't always become law but
they're you know sometimes they're just
messaging bills but you would have
something like
you know baseball and apple pie some
feel good thing and you'd look up on the
screen and there'd be like 20 no books
like okay and then who are those people
and it would be bernie sanders and this
hard left
wing
caucus
and it was constantly they were like you
know equivalent of back benchers like
you would see in a parliamentary system
where they just didn't have any friends
nobody really took them serious the
democrats laughed at them
right because at that point i had
friends on the other side of the aisle
people that i would talk to and that oh
that's the crazy people you know
and
now they're in charge they're in charge
and there's i mean there's not 20
that aren't
you know full-fledged marxists
in one way or wow or at least they have
to pretend that they are and that's
really what this is it's all about power
it's all about how do you get and keep
and hold power and that's what i saw
during my time in washington and i got
to the point where
like when i i knew we were in trouble
and you know i was one of the first guys
to go to parlor and i was one of the
first guys to go to rumble because i've
caught
the the fake news and the
and the social media companies shadow
banning me so i went to these new
platforms because and i and i realized
quickly like man i grew like followers
like no tomorrow and then of course
parlor got nuked by the by big tech yeah
and crazy the rest is history how was
that legal it was it was it was
collusion it was it was it had to be
some kind of you know there's got to be
some kind of anti-trust action or
something to stop this kind of collusion
in the market yeah but then they went to
court and i don't know where those cases
are now but you have to go in many cases
they go to court in their home in their
home court so even the court this has
even reached the courts but where's the
doj and the fbi investigating this and
subpoenaing and going in and
confiscating
cell phones and computers and laptops
okay to build a case to look for the
crime to look for the crime yeah well
look we had i mean look it ultimately
ends up with
supreme court justices something leaking
unprecedented history a decision
pre-leaks out
right that we still haven't got to the
bottom of and then they're out
protesting and threatening supreme court
justices homes which should be illegal
when it comes from you know all the work
you've done who has more influence and
power the intelligence agencies or big
tech social media and do the
intelligence agencies affect big tech
social media
so so remember the intelligence agencies
aren't what is is corrupt here
it is the
the people at the high echelons of the
democratic party operandis
that are running those intelligence
agencies
right so they control all the levers of
power does that make sense this is not
it's the democrats and the democrats are
then sending messaging
to the fake news right because all the
fake news they'll come out boom one day
narratives out there over and over again
they pound away
and then
but then it's tough to tell with it and
then trump was in office and then the
intelligence agencies were working
against him
so you know
yeah yeah because because he didn't
control no
that's kind of republican we have no we
have no power i mean when republicans
get in they can't control it anymore
it's like an it's because what happens
is they put their people in they burrow
them in
right
you're saying that the fb that these
intelligence agencies or at least parts
of them have gone rogue
well
no they're just the yeah they've been
they don't answer to the
commander-in-chief then oh yeah they've
basically gone rogue
they've recruited and they've promoted
and retained people that fit a political
narrative that come from a certain type
of school that think a certain way that
reflect the woke agenda and
in this last congress we saw the
democrats trying to push that type of
woke recruitment
and ideological perspective throughout
more of the intelligence agencies
okay mandating it
look part of the reason why is it it's
it's hard to get we talked about city
states a little bit ago it's hard to get
republicans
to say boy i'd really like to go make a
career
and live in washington dc
and burrow myself in get connected go to
the brookings institute write reports go
work for congress become a lobbyist and
always working i mean republicans for
the most part don't want to do that
right they want to live in
rural maryland right or they want to
live in
in you know rural america but just back
to the question who has more power and
influence
well i would say they're all one i guess
is the short answer nice yeah no they're
they're all kind of one you're
absolutely right yeah you're absolutely
right that's something i've been saying
for for years now and a lot of people
don't understand that there really isn't
much of a difference when it comes to
the decisions the major ones that they
make well now we're getting uh evidence
in these these lawsuits that the the
federal government was instructing
directing big tech to censor people they
didn't like right right and it's been a
cascade we've gotten a little bit here
and now it's now it's full swing now
we've got emails where i think alex
berenson is that's that's a journalist
right yeah where they're like why hasn't
he been banned yet twitter and then
twitter's like okay and then he gets
banned
dr fouchy parody accounts got hit
because the white house demonstrated
them too that is absolutely crazy hey i
think you guys i might have heard you
guys talking about this a bit but
there's some yeah and this sounds
ridiculous because you know
you know but i'm a you know guy that's
been in political business and now and
now uh you know running through social
so i i'm not attuned to this stuff like
you guys are but i had never heard of
this guy named andrew tate
okay yeah
i'd never heard of the guy before right
i mean until like a few weeks ago
and how is it possible it's it's very
similar to the parlor thing right where
overnight parlor boom gets nuked by 30
40 companies right they get cancelled by
everyone
well the same thing i never heard of
andrew tate guy but
it's so odd that everybody canceled them
like he got nuked from every platform
within within what 48 hours yep it's
collision
yeah they they all live in the same area
they all work in the same area yes
emails pro processors website everything
got taken away from him thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there